today we're giving you all the info you
need to know about the dragon ball x
fortnite crossover as well as what you
can expect from the next game pass drop
after leaks rumors and one official
teaser last week the fortnite dragon
ball super collaboration is officially
underway and it's one of the most
expansive crossovers in the battle
royale's history goku vegeta beerus and
bulma skins have been added to the game
with all but beerus sporting alternate
styles palma features a lab cold alt
style vegeta sports base level super
saiyan super saiyan blue and super
saiyan blue evolved styles and goku
brings his base level super saiyan super
saiyan blue and ultra instinct looks
skins will be sold in two bundles while
a third gear bundle will also be made
available for purchase i think the last
time i watched dragon ball was way way
back in the fifth grade
but i think i nailed those names so feed
my ego a little bit drop some clapping
hands emojis in the comment section
alongside the dragon ball crossover
skins multiple in-game events will also
be featured including the dragon ball
power unleash quests that offer special
rewards extra battle pass levels and a
shinring glider to those who complete
quests and collect the dragon balls we
have a complete guide for all of the
fortnite dragon ball challenges over on
gamespot.com so i'll leave a link to
that in the description dragon balls can
be found on multiple fortnite creative
maps featuring prominent locations from
the dragon ball universe the creative
maps include cami's place goku's house
and the room of spirit and time among
others also available will be a special
cruise ship creative map that will play
episodes of dragon ball super in their
entirety for players to watch together
finally two dragon ball themed in-game
items have made their debut the
kamehameha weapon lets players harness
goku's iconic attack during the match
while the nimbus cloud item allows
players to call one during a match and
take to the skies for quick flight and
to be honest the cloud is what pushed me
to finally update my game
when can i sell my car and get one of
these but as cool as all that dragon
ball stuff is when you need a break you
can check out the next wave of xbox game
pass titles eight games in total are
headed to the service before the month
is out unless xbox wants to surprise us
with some additional games as august
progresses out today is the coffee
brewing conversation game coffee talk in
which players brew coffee and then talk
to people about their issues the game is
available across console pc and cloud on
august 23rd midnight fight express comes
to game pass as a day 1 new release this
is a brutal and hyperkinetic brawler
that will be available on console pc and
cloud i really enjoyed my time with the
demo so i'm very excited to get my hands
on the full thing after that game pass
will add the open-ended puzzle game
exa-punks for pc on august 25th while
opus echo of star song full bloom
edition hits game pass for pc that day
as well the next day 1 new release for
game pass is commando 3 hd remaster a
high definition remaster of the tactics
game originally released in 2003 another
day one release is immortality the next
game from her story designer sam barlow
which releases on august 30th for pc
console and cloud also on the 30th is
ubisoft's adventure game immortals
phoenix rising and puzzle platformer
tinykin unfortunately though august 31st
will see a sizeable chunk of games exit
the service so if you haven't played
space-faring sim elite dangerous the
award-winning roguelite hades or the
satisfyingly grisly zombie shooter world
war z you only have a few days left to
do so you can also expect to say goodbye
to two point hospital but seeing how its
successor two point campus was recently
added to game pass it won't be too
bittersweet of a farewell but okay now
i'm gonna need you to hit the comment
section and let me know your favorite
dragon ball character growing up mine
was trunks
is that cool
or is it really lame that i liked trunks
and i still kind of see his character
sometimes and i think he's cool
he's badass
let me know i'll see you tomorrow